We have now reached the hands-on or the exercise portion of this tutorial.
And to do that, what we're going to be working with is a project called Box Hunter.
So Box Hunter is a game where the player is trying to collect boxes for points before
the time runs out.
And there's pickups that will give you more time, score, or jump ability.
There's also platforms that can be set up to move when the user steps on them or fall
or rotate.
And there's also logic that makes a full game loop.
So let's take a look at this now.
So if I come up here and press play, we can see here, here's my player.
I have a timer so I can grab time.
You can see the platform, that jump one will move, or I shouldn't say move, but it will
fall if I stay on it for too long.
The time one rotates.
So there's all types of different things that we can do here.
You can see, oh, it didn't make it.
So I have something that happens.
If I don't make it, I can go to the main menu here.
I can also start, or if let's just jump off the platform again really quick, I can go
to quit.
There we go, quit.
And it will actually quit the game for me.
So again, this makes an entire game loop.
And this is going to serve as the example project that we build off of.
Because oftentimes when we're working on game projects, we don't start from absolutely nothing.
We have something to work with.
So we're working with actors that we pull into the world and we manipulate their properties.
So this is a really great example of that.
Now that we know a little bit more about the project we'll be working with, let's go ahead
and create a new basic level.
And when we do that, we're going to want to also delete the static mesh actor that's added.
So let's pop over to the editor now.
So what I'm going to do is come up here to file, new level, and then we're going to select
this basic right here and hit create.
Now as soon as it does that, we're going to take this bottom floor right here and press
delete to make sure that we've deleted that because we don't actually need that.
So the next thing we want to do here is press the save button up here.
And we're going to look for our levels folder.
And we're going to call this, let's say level underscore zero two.
And then once that is done, what we're going to do next is we're going to come over to
our world settings here.
And we're going to make sure that our game mode is set to BP box.
Now the reason that I want to do that is because if I was to play this now, notice I don't
have anything.
I have no UI.
I don't even actually have a character.
I'm just kind of floating around in the air.
So what I'm going to do is come up here to my window and then we're going to come down
to world settings.
Now with that window selected, it's going to come up here in my tab drawer system right
beside my details panel.
And then we're going to look for our game mode.
And right here under game mode override, we're going to put this to BP box hunter game mode.
All right.
So just to recap, we came here to window world settings.
The reason we did that is because this window wasn't open and we needed access to it.
Once we did that, we came to our game mode override and then we selected the BP box hunter
game mode as our game mode override.
And that is going to give us a player and a UI.
So now we're going to start adding actors to our project.
Before we can add them, we need to be able to find them first.
So you can find actors a number of different ways.
First off, from the quickly add to your project, from this dropdown, we can do things like
place basic actors like blueprints or things like that.
We can place lights or basic shapes like a box or a cube.
We can also find actors using the filters inside of our content browser or the very
powerful search functionality.
So we can search for something by a name or we can enable the filters and we can also
enable the filters and use the search feature.
Now no matter what we have searched for, we are going to need to add it to our project
and we add things one of two ways.
The first way is if we're using the quickly place, once we've searched for something in
this example right here, we've searched for light, we then just click on the object or
I should say the actor that we want and it will be placed inside of the level viewport
somewhere in a relative location to our current camera.
When we are working with stuff in the content browser, once we find something that we want,
we simply drag and drop it right into the level.
Now once we have that actor placed, we're going to need to move it around and we can
do this a couple of different ways.
We can use the gizmo to position it in the world or we can select what we want in the
outliner and then in the details panel, we can use the location, rotation and scale.
So what we are going to do at this point is we are going to set up our level by making
sure that we have a player start, a platform, a depth volume and a wind volume.
So let's pop over to the editor now.
So we're going to hit control space and oops control space here and from our content, I'm
going to come down to blueprints and I'm going to grab my blueprint platform right here.
I'm just going to drag that in and with that in here, I'm going to take its location and
just set it to zero, zero, zero and all this is going to ensure is that when I press play,
the platform is right there ready for me to go.
Alright, so what we're going to do next is we're going to grab this wind volume and then
we're going to do the same thing.
We're going to take its location and set it to zero, zero, zero and then we're just going
to drag it over here like so.
I'm going to hit control space and then with the depth volume, something similar, I'm
going to go to zero, zero, zero but we're going to bring the depth volume down a little
bit and then we're going to hit space bar twice.
We're just going to scale this out like so and then scale it out like so and this is
just going to ensure that if the player happens to fall, you know, if I come here and I'm,
whoops, I fall off of this, there's a way to trigger the restart.
Okay, so next what we're going to do is we're going to talk now a little bit about our actor
details.
So each actor has a details that contain its properties.
For us though on the platform, we have some different actor details like on our pickup
types, we have a time, a score and a jump.
So the time will give us time to the timer score, will give us a score and jump will
increase or decrease the power of our jump.
Now we change those using this pickup type, we can click on the drop down menu and select
none or select any one of these pickups.
There's also some things here for rotate, duration falling and enable platform movement.
So down at the bottom we have our score, jump and time amounts so we can adjust these to
adjust the various score, time and jump amounts that our awarded player runs into those.
For rotate when the user jumps on this, it's going to make it actually rotate the platform.
We'll talk about that in just a second but I want to get to falling.
So falling when enabled will make this platform fall in between about half a second and a
little bit under a second.
One thing to note, you cannot have a falling and rotate enabled at the same time, it will
rotate but it will not fall.
What platform movement does, it actually works in conjunction with duration and platform
movement when enabled allows the platform to move in between two points.
So we'll see here in just a second, we have these points 1 and point 2 and when we enable
platform movement it's going to move between these two points based on the duration right
here.
So let's go over to the editor now and what I'm going to do is I am going to grab this
first blueprint, I'm going to make sure it just says none because that's the spawning
one there.
Then I'm going to hold alt and drag out one, I'm going to just hold down, oops, didn't
mean to do that, hold down alt again and drag out and add another one.
So this one we're going to set to jump, this one we're going to set to score and then let's
hold down alt and move like that.
We'll set this one to time and then I'm going to do this one more time, something like that,
maybe pull the wind volume up, there we go.
So what we have now is when I press play, I've got my score over here, I've got a jump
over here and then you can see I jumped really high and then I've got the time and then there
we go, I can win and things like that.
So what I'm going to do next is let's take a look at some of these platform properties.
So we're just going to grab this platform right here and I'm going to change this platform
type to none for the time being so we can have a look at it.
So let's take a look at what rotate does.
If I click rotate and press play and we jump onto this platform over here, you can see
the platform starts to rotate.
Not anything too crazy, just a cool little thing that the player has to account for.
And then if we do falling, what falling is going to do, oops, wrong one, let me just
play that again here, falling, it's this platform over here, is going to make the platform fall,
there we go and that can make a really great, you can have a bunch of these together so
that's a risk versus reward like there could be three or four of them and the player can
run across them and they have just enough time to get across them and before it falls
so it can be really fun.
And then we have this enable platform movement.
So to get the movement to work, we need to click on these little L1 so you can just click
on them and these represent the location.
So it's going to move between these.
If I press play here, we'll see here, see it's moving like that.
The other cool thing we can do with these two is we can also bring them up like that.
So it can go diagonally and then if I was to bring this down to say like one, bring
it down to one, oh my number lock wasn't on, there we go, to one, there we go.
You see it goes really fast or if I was to set it to like 15, it would go very slow.
So with that said, what I want everybody to do, I'm going to pause this tutorial for now
and make a little course.
So we want to have something that has a, you know, a starch, a few little obstacles to
the player to navigate around and when we come back, we will finish up with adding some
backgrounds and some additional things to make this look super unique and finish up with
publishing.
I will see you back here once you have added a few more platforms.
All right, so now that you have added a few boxes or I should say mini boxes to simulate
kind of a city or whatever futuristic landscape or environment you have envisioned, the next
thing that I want to talk about is adding some Niagara VFX admitters to simulate traffic
as this is going to be pretty common throughout any project workflow.
Now with our admitter, it's actually been set up so that when we placed it in the world
and we go over to the details panel, we're going to have some things like mesh scale,
the plane size, spawn count and velocity that we can adjust.
So what these do is the mesh scale scales the size of the box.
So it's going to give us a larger box on one of these axes, the X, Y or Z.
The plane size, this represents the size of the spawnable area that this is going to cover.
So if we want to spawn over a larger area, we're going to make this a much bigger number.
If we want to spawn over a smaller area, we're going to make this a much smaller number.
Spawn count affects how many of these are spawned and then velocity controls how fast
this is going to move in a given axis.
And you'll see we can use velocity to kind of make these look like they're starting in
one direction, kind of drifting off to another.
So let's pop over to the editor now.
Take a look at how we would add these.
So for this level here, what I'm going to do is maybe add some going across the back
here.
So I'm going to hit control space and we're going to come to our effects.
And right here we have our NS floating traffic.
So we're going to bring that in to, remember it's drag and drop.
And what I'm going to do now is I'm actually going to hit F to kind of focus in on this
because it was a little far away and kind of hard for me to see.
So it looks like it actually got placed kind of far away from me.
So I'm going to use my axes to kind of bring it in.
My play area is way over here.
So it actually got moved really far away from me.
So I'm going to just try to bring that back in like so.
There we go.
Let's go.
So this is my play area here.
So yeah, there we go.
Maybe we have some traffic like that.
Now it does, when this spawns in, it just spawns in.
It has no fade in or anything like that.
So you want to make sure that you're not showing necessarily the spawn in with these.
And the next thing that we're going to do is come down to its user parameters.
And let's like maybe adjust some of this.
So let's set that to like.
These are going to be some really big ones.
They should look really large.
I'm going to hit G here.
There we go.
We should have some really large looking flying bits of traffic there.
And then what we can do here is let's set our spawn count.
Maybe we set it to like 15.
So there's a bunch of them.
Okay 15 is maybe a little bit too much.
So we'll set that down to like maybe seven.
We might need to set this to like five.
Make them a little bit shorter.
Okay and then what we'll do is let's do this to like 3500 for their velocity or not their
oops.
Let's reset that.
I meant to change their velocity here to 3500 or I think that needs to be at 3500.
And then one of the other cool things we can do with this is like let's set this to 150.
So what's going to happen is they should end up looking like they're going up.
We might need to actually just increase this to like maybe.
Yeah there we go.
So now what I want everybody to do is just do something similar.
Spend some time now and you can see here that we've added a couple of traffic effects
to this level.
So just spend some time now adjusting the traffic to get something that you like, something
that looks kind of cool with your particular project.
And when you're done we will talk about working with the level lighting.
Now that you've added some visual effects and background objects let's talk about working
with our level lighting.
Now for this particular project the level lighting is fairly simple in its setup.
It makes use of a sky atmosphere, an exponential height fog, and a post processing volume as
well as a directional light to simulate the sun and a skylight to help with the bounce
light or the indirect light.
All of these things are needed to work together in order to give you the best result.
However that's not necessarily the way that you have to go about it.
In some instances such as if you were using say baked lighting and you had a light mass
importance volume or you were using a skydome actor.
You might not be using say volumetric clouds or be relying more on post process or properties
in the skydome to represent things like the atmosphere or the cloud interaction.
The setup that we're using in this particular project is going to result in the most accurate
form of lighting but that's going to come at a direct cost of performance.
So while this is going to look really great and be easy to work with it is going to be
expensive in terms of performance.
Let's just pop over to the ender now and see what we have to work with.
So easiest thing to do is hold down control alt and L. That's going to access a little
lighting gizmo that you can then manipulate by moving the mouse around.
And this is the method that I prefer working with when it comes to positioning my skylight,
getting that really cool lighting angle that I want.
If we kind of look up while we do this we can see that as I start to position it towards
the horizon I can get these really really great looking low cast light here.
And I'll just say that it is also going to be working with our shadows.
Clouds in the background we can see the clouds picking up those subtle colors and even right
there the shadows look really really the shadows.
The clouds are looking as though they are shadowed and they're picking up those darks
really really really well.
So some of the other things that we can adjust in this system so I'm going to come all the
way back up to the top here.
We can go to our exponential height fog.
So the exponential height fog is going to control well the fog.
So if I was to maybe turn the density of this down you can see here I'm making the fog less
dense.
I can also adjust the height of it as well so I can bring it up and make things below
a little bit harder to see or a little bit more included.
I also have a secondary fog here that I can do to add some more fog effects somewhere
else.
I can enable my volumetric fog which is going to give me this just really great and interesting
looking fog overlay on top of it.
It's also going to give the fog a more 3D look and make it appear more that it looks
like inside of nature.
We also have our post processing so one thing to know about post processing there are a
ton of settings in here but the most important one is going to be down here and it is called
and I am just not seeing it somewhere.
There we go.
Right underneath post process volume settings.
Infinite extent unbound.
So by enabling this what we do is if this is disabled which is the default it will this
post process volume will only work if the camera is inside of the post process volume.
That would mean we would have to scale the volume to fit this entire scene.
If we enable this what that means is that now this post process volume will be applied
to the scene no matter where we are in the scene and then by setting this this means
that I can now come up here and basically set anything that I want.
I can come up here to my temperature and adjust this however which way that I want and so
on and so forth.
Our sky atmosphere one of the things we can do is we can adjust things like the ground
radius or the atmosphere height to give us some different colors or a little bit more
control.
The only thing that I would really suggest you adjust in here is with the artistic direction
unless you are setting something up for some different type of planet or atmosphere that
is different than Earth.
If you are trying to adjust these properties up here like the atmosphere height or the
atmosphere ray length or something like that you might not get the results that you want
if you are trying to adjust the color.
Better results are going to be down here in the art direction by changing like the luminance
factor the height fog can contribution and things like that.
The sky light is going to control again our bounce light so we could increase the intensity
on this to give us a little bit more detail in our we can see it here in the building
is in the background it is just going to make them a little more intense.
Then our volumetric cloud this has a couple of controls that are in the actor here so
this is going to allow us to control like the layer height and things like that.
If we come over here to the material double click on it you can see here in the material
we have a whole bunch of other parameters that we can enable and adjust including things
like enabling storms and we have our cloud general layout and then the actual shape and
look of the cloud so a lot of parameters and things that we can adjust right here when
it comes with working with lights because again when we are working with lights especially
in an outdoor environment it is more than just working with a directional light it is
working with all of these different things in conjunction together to give us the final
image.
Alright so before we finish up the last thing that we need to do is modify some of our blueprint
code to point to our level that we want to load because right now if we were to play
this or publish it it is going to use the default level so this is pretty simple to
do what we are going to do is over here inside of the editor I am going to hit control space
and then I am going to look for our UI and we are going to look for our UB for widget
blueprint main menu we are just going to double click on that to open it up.
Once that is open we are going to come over here to the graph and the graph is pretty
simple we have a start and a quit so the start if we zoom in on it we have on start and then
open level and we have this by object reference so right here we are just going to click the
level that we want to open which is going to be level 2 or whatever your level name
is once you compile and save this that is the level that will be open so this is the
last thing that needs to be done in order for our project to be ready to publish.